yeah battle scenes are actually
very hard to write um i've of course
done quite a few of them in uh the song
of ice and fire books
um very different from marco's battles
of course he's uh he's dealing with uh
warfare on other planets and space with
high-tech weaponry and uh
missiles and and uh
bombs and
projectiles of various sorts and i'm
dealing with big hairy guys with axes
and swords wearing metal and trying to
stick each other with spears or firing
arrows
but some of the basic challenges are
still the same no matter the level of
technology or weaponry
i've read a lot of military history
i've i've always been fascinated by that
and it kind of frustrated by the way
battles are often done in state
television and film in particular
um
the challenge is uh
to try to get both aspects of the battle
but the general's eye and the private
side you know the general's eye
you know the general's sitting back in
the battle and he's he's seeing the
front and he's seeing
okay my left flank is getting pushed
back and i better send in my reserve
there and let me swing the cavalry
around here and here's some important
high ground i better add here so he's
seeing all the all the tactical and
strategic aspects of the battle and he's
playing it out like a
chess
um
game
um and that's fascinating for someone
who likes
military history and the aspects of
warfare that are covered by that uh but
it can tend to be dry now the private
side view is much more visceral it's you
know here i am standing on the battle
and oh my god this big guy is coming at
me with an axe i better get my shield up
oh my god he hit me well wait a minute i
stand him in the belly now his guts are
falling out it's much more visceral it's
much more exciting but you don't have
any sense of the bigger battle so the
real challenge of writing a good battle
scene
is uh
to try to capture both of those in the
scene to try to give the reader a sense
of of the tactics of the battle and
what's happening on a larger battlefront
while still
putting you in the eyes and ears of your
your protagonist and kind of putting
your reader right in this
middle of the action which is what's
going to get the blood pumping and the
excitement going
um next subject war and
violence of course there is a lot of
violence in a book especially in the
santa fe ice and fire but
you treated it very seriously it's never
for fun
it's very relationship
with your life during the vietnam war
the way you treat violence
well you know war has been
a central part of fantasy since tolkien
and even before
i mean you can already go back to the
elite and you know you've got a fantasy
classic set around the trojan war
so
i think
it's certainly a legitimate subject to
write about
but i do think it is a subject that's of
great importance maybe the most
important thing
of all
and
it should not be treated
i don't know for fun um
because it's not i don't know to me at
least it's not funny yeah you can get
humor out of everything i don't want to
let me
rephrase that
you can do funny things about war sure
people have done and who do and you can
find black humor in anything and that's
good too i appreciate black humor
but for me
i worked in network television
for uh american network television for
10 years back in the 80s and 90s
and
being a broadcast station we were
subject to network standards and
practices that is censorship
and they they tried to keep out old sex
was one of the things and the other
thing is they they always tried to tone
down the violence in fact they probably
would have said well we don't want any
violence in our show
but we do want lots of action
and action is what is action the network
might give you a different definition
but to my mind action is bloodless
violence
you know you you see action an action
film here's an exciting car chase and
all the cars are are
slamming against each other and they're
flipping over and they're going into the
ditch
and
the the
flames are engulfing the cars that have
crashed you never actually see the
twisted bodies you never see the person
who when the car slammed into each other
their leg was severed and they're
bleeding to death in the in the front of
that car you never see the drivers
inside the car that's just blown up
screaming in agony as the flesh consumes
them um
that's the sign of action the network
doesn't want to show you because it
might disturb you
well sorry i think you should be
disturbed
i'm
my position on this has really
kind of articulated over the last
decades since i did this and i'm against
action i i mean i'm you can do a
straight character piece with no deaths
in it and and no
no one being in jeopardy and all that
and that's fine you know you can write
my dinner with andre or or um a woody
allen comedy and all that but if you're
going to do something where people are
dying if you're going to do a war story
especially then show war the way it is
and the way it is is complicated because
the truth is we like war why is there
this aptitude for action because like
achilles who had the choice between a
short and glorious life or a long and
boring one he chose a short and glorious
life and he wanted to go out in a blaze
of glory and uh indeed he did
um
the ancients always talked about the
glories of war and you can still see
some of that in the pageantry in the
middle ages which i reflect
in game of thrones and the knights with
their armor their armor shining in the
sun the banners and in a world that was
largely brown and mud colored here were
these incredible warriors with their
heraldry with their eagles and their
lions and their wolves flying from the
banners
it has a beauty to it of frightening
beauty but when then when those armies
clash then you get the severed limbs and
you get the lakes of blood and you get
all of that and i think if you're gonna
honestly treat with that material show
both sides and that's what i try to do
show the glory but also show the pain
and the grief and the cost of the glory
the price of war
i'm not a pacifist
but i was a conscientious objector
during the vietnam war
um
because i thought that particular war
was immoral
and
illegal in fact as most wars by america
have been illegal over the last
well pretty much my lifetime
they would always ask you when you
applied but you know you had to have an
interview and you had to answer
questions when you applied for country
objective status and there were some
draft boards in the united states that
only wanted to correct it to total
pacifists people who at least would
claim why i would never fight under any
circumstances i would never take a human
life i certainly don't
claim that for myself i never have taken
a human life but i think on the right
circumstances i could and they always
say well what would you do if you know
adolf hitler was raping your grandmother
yeah i would kill adolf hitler if he was
raping my grandmother
i might kill him just for being adolf
hitler uh
but you know it was always would you
fight in world war ii yeah yeah muslims
would fight in world war ii um
but world war ii wasn't
the war on the menu at the present time
and one of the things i decided then
grew up grappling with these issues was
that ho chi minh was not a wolf hitler
and in fact he was certainly not sauron
the issue that much of us have to deal
with as fantasy writers it's all very
easy to to always write these books in
which way sauron is always the villain
or more goth even worse or you know and
you're writing you're fighting against
the dark lord or the rotten one or the
bad guy or
you know lord
malice or whatever the hell you're gonna
call your your big bad but
real life doesn't really offer us that
and i wanted to inject a certain level
of realism into
the kind of fiction i was writing
thank you very much